um slightly different talk but the the
flavor is we're going to look at some
machine learning models
um
so I guess my title is very long the key
ideas I'm going to look at Gans and tell
you some of the information Theory
foundations of it and also connect them
to loss functions but take this
perspective of what is the Divergence
you should pick for gas to minimize
exactly right and this is Joint work
with Monica who's here and Gautam who
was my first talk is now a professor in
India and Kyle who started this work as
an undergraduate student who's now
graduated in the Masters
um so again generative adversarial
networks I'm sure everybody knows about
it uh chat GPT doesn't use it but this
is still the mother of all uh models
that are generating synthetic data right
so I'm going to focus on this there's
some nice mathematical structures here
to understand so the key idea of Gans is
that you have two functions and they
operate in an adversarial manner you
take real data you feed it into one of
the functions that function is actually
a discriminator is going to actually
make a decision between real data and
some other data that's fed to it it's
just synthetic data and the synthetic
data is generated by another function
that operates on um say distributions
coming from a lower dimensional latent
space right so the discriminator
uh his goal is to distinguish between
the real data and the synthetic data and
the generator's goal is to take that
feedback from the discriminator and
improve its synthetic outputs right
um my posture gotten really likes this
he calls it a game between a
counterfeiter and police
um where of course uh
the job here as a counterpillar is to
win against the police right so ideally
the discriminator should not be able to
distance
so Gans are used but even if you're a
surprise chat GPD does not um it uses
larger diffusion models but
um Gans have been used to do a lot of
things especially if we go look at what
Nvidia does and so on
um and including using for protein uh
synthesis all right so let's dive into
the math a little bit uh Gans were
introduced by Goodfellow and his
collaborators about almost 10 years back
now and what I'm going to call the
vanilla again right so you stare at this
I mean we figured out that there's a
game being played between the
discriminatory generator so
mathematically that becomes an in soup
over two functional spaces right the G
functional space of the generator and
we're going to uh you know parametrize
this by some Theta and the D functional
spaces the discriminator
parameterization right what matters is
that this is a zero-sum game they both
want to minimize and maximize the same
function and this function if you look
at it this is what um good fellow at all
picked it has this form where
this is the output of D is the output of
the discriminator and you put a log in
front of it looks like a log loss here
it is and that is averaged over the
samples from the two data and one log
one minus that is averaging samples from
the uh generated data and or really from
the uh the latent space of the generator
okay all right so
for this setting D is actually a output
between zero and one and so if the
discriminator output 0 that means it um
uh the discriminator outputs one that
means it's real data the discriminator
zero that means it's actually faked
right so ideally you want this output to
be one half
okay okay
um so if you look at this optimization
and you start with the inner
optimization which is the supremum over
this function it's not so hard you can a
law of unconscious statistician you
write it out in terms of the
distributions on the X itself and you
minimize this you get an optimal
discriminator of this one now we're in a
universe where all functionals are
possible so this would be the best
functional for the discriminator you
plug that back in what you get that the
generator minimizes over is simply twice
the Shannon versions between the true
distribution and the generated
distribution minus
the cost
okay right um and for those
who have forgotten Jensen China is
asymmetric damage
um so you know you said this you go hey
yeah this is a this is a Divergence we
all know it comes from KL so if you can
do this why can't we try and minimize
the different emotions so in fact they
answer the question the answer to that
question was formulated by no reason at
all in 2016 where they said well you
know you don't need to have Dan which is
now the vanilla again you can have an
Afghan which minimizes any afterwards so
how do I write it in that value function
form you take an F Divergence and you
can write its convex conjugate um and
then you
so you can take the very you know take
the after which is definition and you
plug it back in you get this form for
the value function of the objective that
the two players minimize and maximize
okay
so
um
so depending on the F you choose
you can get back to vanilla again
or the hellenge again or the total
so these were the Gans sort of people
are interested in fact no business paper
is all kinds of F's and all kinds of
corresponding gaps
right
um following all this that will work by
others the wgan washer and then that
many of you may be very familiar with it
was introduced not just uh as another
Afghan it is not an Afghan but to
actually address some of the problems
with vanilla Gans
um there have been other Gans introduced
that really take different uh
divergences such as the Cuban gandarin
again and so on all right so what I'm
going to do in this talk is really tell
you that
this value function
at least in the context of divergences
can be written in terms of loss
functions
so you stare at this for just a moment
ago it looks like it looks like long
loss right in fact it looks like
um you know I'm taking data samples and
I'm minimizing it looks like some kind
of risk minimization right so why can't
I stick any other loss in there a loss
that actually maps to zero one what we
call in machine learning as a class
probability estimation loss a soft loss
right so the uh a loss operates on two
things the ground truth Y which is
binary zero one and Y hat which is an
estimate of Y over zero one
okay all right so
um what we want to restrict if we want
to map this to some loss form is to
restrict that this the symmetric loss is
actually the the this loss is actually
symmetric in the following
so
what am I doing here I am now replacing
log D of w by some loss and I have a
negative here because in classic uh you
know this community is a classifier so
it's minimizing some loss and since
we've written in this game form as a
super moon so I just take a negative
so the interesting thing that comes from
this Gan part is that you're minimizing
on the real samples that's one here the
data from the real and minimizing this
partial loss for the synthetic samples
from the data from the center
so in in machine learning literature
this L1 and l0 will be typically called
partial loss
okay so but for the Gantt setting you do
want it to satisfy one constraint that
um that when the discriminator is half
you should get the best performance
right that's when it cannot distinguish
so we want the loss to satisfy this
country okay
um and convexity of this loss function
suffice us to do
um so I'm going to uh give you our first
result that we have which is that this
min max optimization that I showed you
um
in any symmetric so it's a metric for
this loss as I Define reduces to
minimizing and after which
so I started with losses and what I'm
telling you is that the inner
optimization the supremum over this loss
formulation that I have is going to
become an after version such that the
overall optimization is going to be an
infamous
okay
so
you give me a loss it is equivalent to
minimizing and afterwards just you give
me an after version so symmetric after
versions there exists a loss
okay it's actually super cute and the
proof really comes from this very nice
paper by new and Wainwright and Bartlett
um a good decade or so back you've got
to write this loss in a margin based
form I don't have time to go over it but
it's it's really a cute result okay
um so what this tells me is that there
exists a loss for any after version
symmetric after versions that you want
to minimize okay and sometimes it's
easier to work with loss functions
all right so an example of this is a
kind of loss that I've been working on
for a while it came out of some really
nice work with Oliver which was
motivated by a work with Aaron Wagg
worked by Aaron Wagner on maximum
leakage
um Oliver and I was staring at his paper
and then I was like oh well we should
think about General expectation guessing
and he goes goes out for a day comes
back with the formulation and then it
took me a year to figure out we can put
it in some machine learning context
right those who know all over here are
smiling
um so here's our loss right it's Alpha
is a parameter slightly different Alpha
from Cynthia's in the morning but
um so I've written there's more in a
machine learning setting why is either
zero one so one of the terms will be
zero right so y hat is your estimate
which is between zero and one now
instead of just taking y hat
which will give you log loss by the way
if you take um
a little bit careful uh instead of
taking what I had to take well I had
raised to the power of one minus one
over off
so if I uh
plug this loss in
to this model what I'm going to tell you
is that this loss itself for Alpha
equals one
uh recovers log loss for Alpha equals
one-half it requires the exponential
loss and for Alpha equals infinity it
actually recovers the soft zero one loss
okay so correspondingly the divergences
then become the Jensen Shannon diverges
the hellinger Divergence and the total
variations
all right so this is a lot of function
we were obsessed with and we wanted to
understand how it works uh in the Gantt
setting and so in the Gad setting this
loss function so the inner optimization
if you put this Alpha loss in gives you
what is what we now call the arimoto
Divergence a remote came up with this
Divergence and it completely came up
with this loss itself in a completely
different context of understanding what
happens to probability of error when the
rate is over capacity and um then Vida
took it over and did a lot of stuff and
he named it the remote approaches so the
remotely Divergence of this is the
systematic all right so and uh for
different values Alpha you recover some
of the known results
okay so the first the second result that
I'm going to tell you is we're still in
this setting where we can express all
functionals
but now I'm going to ask the question if
you get more and more samples
asymptotically is there any difference
in these divergences should I pick a
particular loss or a different loss
should I uh consider a particular
Divergence or a different directions
right so this I I kamalaka and our
collaborators have this really nice
concept of equivalence and convergence
and they see two divergences are
equivalent if for a sequence of
probabilities and the second probability
measure being fixed right if uh one goes
to zero asymptotically
if and only if the other was just zero
acid okay and what they showed uh well
okay
and his collaborators showed is that the
Jensen Shannon Divergence is uh
equivalent in convergence to the total
variation
and then children at all I mean you at
all showed that the there is a in terms
of convergence the Jensen Shannon the
hellinger and the total variation are
equipped
what we did was we showed that
um
all Alpha diversion uh The Immortal
divergences are equivalent convergence
now we can actually generalize this
result to say that all symmetric after
versions are equivalent in convergence
okay
um so if you give me the sequence this
is exactly what I've written and it
actually simplifies some of the earlier
proofs because it is based on this
really cute result by Feldman and
austral it says that any F Divergence
symmetric F Divergence is bounded above
and below by functions of the total
variation
so that is the second result the third
result that is also somewhat theoretical
is
moving to a slightly different worldview
in reality we cannot have all possible
functionals for the generator and the
discriminator right oftentimes all these
models are trained on neural networks
and neither do you have infinite number
of samples from the real data you could
generate infinite number of samples of
the synthetic data but they're only as
good as the model you train them so you
can look at a setting where you have
finite number of samples
okay
um so in this setting now we have
empirical estimates of the real and the
generated distribution
right and
um
this immediately leads to the following
problem that you cannot get a precise
estimate of the Divergence when you only
finite samples in fact uh Aurora at all
showed that when you have finite number
of samples you are you know low about it
away from the true Divergence by a
certain amount
for say the washer and gas for the
Afghans and so on so forth so what they
said is effectively we need to have a
better estimate of how close
the true the these two distributions are
to one another you still want to
estimate how good a gun is
but you no longer have infinite number
of samples or infinite capacity of your
models so what they did in this setting
was they introduced a notion called
neural network distance and what that is
is the fall
all right so this is their definition
and it says
there's this estimate coming out of the
discriminator right DW
um say it's between zero and one now you
take this
and you take this as a supreme over all
possible
generative
discriminator functions right so in in
in
in the in in the the most general
setting you you have a supreme inside
right that's what leads you to a
Divergence that's the game the the
generator is trying to minimize and the
discriminator is trying to maximize a
particular function of value function
we no longer can get that Divergence
because we're in the finite sample in
the final capacity setting so in this
setting we Define this as a proxy for
Divergence and so this proxy they call
it the neural network distance
okay all right so
this is now
going to be used to evaluate how good is
your model that you learned okay so
first thing we can do is we can take
that neural network distance and
generalize it as follows you can take it
for any uh loss function that you have
and keep in mind the loss function is of
this form just to keep it simple and not
have a negative sign I've just written
it as Phi here right so we're going to
generalize it from there set up to the
following okay so this is just a
generalized neural network distance
right you plug T in there you get back
the Aero residual lateral distance okay
so what have we done here this is the
function we're going to use
to claim that this is a measure of
distance
between uh two distributions
all right so here's our third result and
it says the following suppose you have n
samples of real data and M samples from
your latent space that you're generating
and M random samples in your latent
dimensional space so this is what you
use to train your Gan and you use a
partial loss that is actually lipsticks
right so elf
should yes so then with high probability
this is the kind of
so here's the setting what we want to
understand is that you
the reality is you only have estimates
of these two distributions from the
finite samples right based on these
estimates you can take those neural
network distance you can minimize this
over your neural architectures that are
possible you will get the best
generators model so if I take this
generators model and I plug it in
to this neural network this is that we
have defined and compare that to what
you can do if you can allow for all
possible generators here
over the two distributions then this
distance this is what's called a
estimation error so this estimation
error can then be bounded by the
following quantities okay
um this was first studied for the
neural network distance presented
earlier by uh Liang and her
collaborators so we sort of generalized
this for the um
for any CPE loss and in particular these
constants that you have here really
depend on the neural network parameters
okay I I apologize that I've left out a
lot of details that makes it hard to
understand it fully but in the interest
of time I'm sort of going to do that
okay so this proof actually Builds on
their work but it also leverages a
because word
so
and liang's work the D can be anything
over the Rios in ours it's actually
limited to zero to one so then we use a
contraction Lemma
um on router marker complexity and and
we can also plug in our own loss
function which is allow for the alpha
loss and we can get other optimal
results when Alpha is infinity okay
which means we can get lower bounds
which are which match the upper bounds
in
in square roof and making some
assumptions that you have lots of
samples for the uh
generated data and you have a value
activation
I apologize that I will give you all
kinds of details but okay
um I want to focus most of the stock on
understanding what should be the right
value function you should use and again
like is it enough to use vanilla gas
what are the problems in training Gans
can that be addressed using loss
functions
okay so let's go back this is our game
between it is a zero-sum game but keep
in mind that the min max or if so is not
equal to soup and so this can be solved
in one shot which is what I told you
about right this is the optimal
discriminator you can put any loss in
for example I'm going to look at Alpha
loss from now on which induces the alpha
Gan as we call it right so this is your
optimal discriminator what really
happens is when actually Alpha goes
smaller and smaller you actually get a
very cautious discriminator which I will
clarify in a moment on the other hand as
Alpha goes to Infinity you actually get
a discriminator that's very confident
which makes the maximum likelihood
estimate on the output
makes a hard position
all right
um
stopping at any point in time if you
have questions or if you didn't follow
anything I said even then you should
stop me but uh so here are some
major issues in training Gans which is
why some people like the diffusion
models better
here are four problems that I'm going to
list out in training at the first one is
what is called Vanishing gradients which
means when you start out you're starting
out with some you know two neural
network models you're starting out with
some arbitrary distribution typically
gaussian for the latent space of the
generator and you get all this real data
the discriminator is very confident it
can distinguish between real and
generated data right so what happens is
that when the discriminator is that
continent you take those log functions
uh
the generator's losses little to no
gradient when the discriminator is very
confident
as a result the generator function
cannot move very well so then it cannot
respond and it doesn't learn right so
that's one problem that's a training
instability another is even if you could
fix that problem that I just talked
about you can get the gradients of the
generator if the generator were able to
move towards the real distribution
as it approaches the real distribution
it can have exploding gradients I'm
going to show you examples of all this
but this is yet another problem okay
these and a combination of other
problems can lead to what are called
mode collapse where the generator gets
very happy that it learned a few modes
it can fool the discriminator on these
modes and somehow it doesn't move out of
them to learn how the mood
okay
and
a problem that's not talked about too
much but is quite a serious problem is
that as of all neural networks
hyperparameter initialization matters a
lot
how many epochs should you train it for
in fact it's been observed for vanilla
against that the longer you train you
can actually you can learn the
distribution and then just fly away from
the distribution make it completely
unstable at some point that's because of
these exploding gradients right so it's
very dependent on the initial seats and
in particular the number of the learning
rate and the number of epochs okay
and in fact the learning rate affects
the convergence
and
if you choose the loss function
appropriately you can reduce this
dependence a bit
so I'm going to use a toy example to
highlight some of these instabilities so
on this plot on the left you see the
real distribution that's in blue it's a
gaussian with a mean minus three and
variance 0.5 and you're starting off
with this distribution right which is
mean minus one and same bearings luckily
you started the same there just looks
easier right so
any loss function you use whether it's
Alpha equals one which is your vanilla
gun or any other Alpha here this is your
optimal discriminator let's assume that
you have enough capacity that you can
achieve this optimal discriminator okay
now how does this optimal discriminator
look so on the left keeping your focus
on the left this is what the optimal
discriminator looks like when Alpha is
equal to one which means you're using
the vanilla again the discriminator
remember it takes values from zero to
one it's very confident for the real
data and it's very confident
and a zero right and if you look at the
generators loss of the same for the same
Alpha this is what it looks like it has
really zero gradient
where you are and then the gradient sort
of decreases so if you're here which is
where you started you have no gradient
to move anywhere
okay so now what if I changed Alpha a
little bit so I'm going to increase
Alpha because I'm just moving in some
particular direction keep in mind as you
increase Alpha the discriminator gets
very confident remember at the limit it
actually is a maximum likelihood
discriminator is going to pick the most
likely point so here is your Alpha and
and and so you see that
um you still have Vanishing gradients
okay
um it's just that it doesn't decrease it
actually flattens out here right and the
limit of alpha Infinity literally they
overlap and you get the discriminator
gets very very confident
so why don't we tweak Alpha and go in
the other direction so Alpha 0.5 I start
getting some gradients here right so
Alpha 0.2 I get even more gradients
why because the discriminator is less
confident
because the discriminator is less
confident it allows the generator loss
to actually move
okay
um so in fact you put more mass here
that in turn converts to having non-zero
degrees gradients here
but Alpha zero is almost
tuning Alpha okay so if you tune off for
less than one you get more gradient for
the generator as I just showed you right
because the discriminator is less
confident you really need that at the
beginning of trade okay you create a
better smoother landscape
but another side effect is that you may
if you look here your brains get steep
very quickly
unfortunately so you may provide too
large of the gradients for the generator
especially when it starts approaching
the real sound which is what was
happening in that plot okay so this was
this will result in too much movement
because
um as you get closer and closer you
really can't and you just get repelled
away from the real data okay all right
so this was not a problem that we
observed in fact the vanilla again good
fellow at all know about this problem so
the way they address this problem in
their setting right forget all these
they don't know about Alpha loss they
are in this setting how do they take
care of this they said well let's just
tweak this generator's loss
the reason it has zero gradients is the
way this function works I'm going to
throw out uh I'm going to change the
source function keep in mind if you
change the generator's loss it's no
longer a zero sum game okay but that's
what they did they have what is called
this such it's called the non-saturating
loss because in the previous setting the
generators loss was saturating and you
had no gradients so they're proposing
non-saturating loss which is but now
it's just it's a vlog of 1 minus C it's
minus log d
okay
all right so uh the the problem is this
this this still suffers remote collapse
and it still suffers from the problem
that when you get closer to
some real points you can get repelled
okay and it's very sensitive to hyper
parameter initialization all right so we
can ask the question
why don't we just use this Alpha loss I
mean we've been talking about it it
provides some interesting divergences
why don't we plug that
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to compare the non-saturated
setting of the vanilla again with a
non-saturated version of the alpha loss
okay so now we're in this
what I would call a non-zero-sum game
because they just come in and Generator
are minimizing the optimizing different
functions okay go back to the same toy
example all right
um so Alpha equals one except now the
generator's loss is different so instead
of having vanish ingredients you
actually start having high gradients
all right if I may Alpha larger than one
my gradients don't blow up so much okay
on the other hand if I make alpha less
than one which gave me all this great
you know ability to move to the real
data unfortunately I have more
hello
okay perfect all right
that's so worth okay so so what I want
you to take away is the following making
Alpha smaller allows the discriminator
to be less confident and gives you
gradients at the generators initial
points on the other hand if I take the
non-saturated version of the
discriminator's loss it can also have a
problem of exploding gradients
Okay so
this is just what I said so can I ask
the following question can I combine a
confident a less confident discriminator
with a more stable generator looks so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
generalize this different objective game
that good fellow themselves came up with
by changing the generators function
to do something a little bit more
General I'm going to use a different
loss function of loss but different
Alpha for the discriminator and a
different Alpha for the generator and I
want to make it clear that this kind of
dual objective gas is not our idea there
have been others who have looked at it
but what I think we've been able to do
is to correlate it closely with uh
training and stabilities besides the
least great again which also did that
so I'm going to sort of stop here
because it's a plug for the poster that
my student is going to give
um so here's our new game
it doesn't have the same objective for
the generator and the discriminator
there are two different objectives each
one uses this this value function that
uses different losses different outfits
okay the optimal discriminator is going
to be the same because this is just
optimizing that function it's just now
that is Alpha D and then you get a
uh you get a different Divergence here
okay so we can actually do a lot of
theory on this go to Monica stop
um we can also obtain estimation error
bonds and we've tested on some really
nice data sets synthetic and publicly
available and the story we have and we
did something that I've not seen in the
literature and correct me if they're
wrong we really trained over hundreds of
seeds I'm almost not seen this anywhere
in the Gan literature okay and over
hundreds of C is what we can show is
like much better or buses to training
all right
um so summary we have a nice way of
connecting various diversion space Gans
to loss functions and we can show that
many of these symmetric after versions
are very equivalent Convergence Theory
what really matters in practice your
Finance samples finite capacity what
kind of bounds can you give on those
but to me I think the most interesting
is that what is the right Afghan you
should think what is the right
Divergence Divergence you should
minimize
one way to look at our work is to say
that we give some operational
interpretation to these are Immortal
divergences looking at them through the
lens of the discriminator as a
classifier and how it affects training
instabilities or stabilities
so right there under all these papers
you can
all right
questions
yes Matthew so I think one of the things
I like is you have a very clean
parametrization as a function of alpha
does it make sense to schedule Alpha
during training
Alpha is a high performance that's right
but you know as you train you again
at the same time right yes so it makes
sense to schedule the alpha
you could it just makes it that much
harder in fact um
the larger the images they've been
looking in earlier images that you train
on
[Music]
um
it's it
you'll start seeing that the
discriminators function matters the most
the generator can be at one it's going
to do fine uh the Discrimination
function matters the most
we've been thinking about adaptive but
it's not clear to us that we need to do
that because we're seeing a lot of
stability when we make the discriminator
less confident because
you think making the discovery more
contrary as a train is better but these
Gans can very quickly move away from a
mood
when you do those things
so keeping the discriminator less
confident really helps
but maybe the generator I mean in the
generator's context it's not about more
confidence or not it's really about what
is the Divergence here and whether you
have enough gradients to move so you
don't want exploring or Vanishing so
that's a very fine line there
yes
several other baby heuristic approaches
people have proposed to deal with
multiple apps like unrolled units and I
think again I'm not in I don't know the
latest in this topic but you know there
was people talked about passagestein
Gans and how they were better than the
vanilla ones
so you know as far as so you can view
this as you know change the loss
function and then this is like a fix for
Mortal Kombat and then on the other hand
you can view algorithmic Innovations you
could do while training to deal with
mode collapse while not changing the
loss function
so is there sort of a middle ground in
between where one could use you know
some sort of hybrid training strategy
but at the same time maybe play with the
loss function itself right yeah
every guy has a set of problems I think
adversarial models inherently have
instabilities because of the game
um so you're correct about that
um I think
uh to come back to your question can you
keep maybe vanilla again and change
algorithmic methods it only goes so far
to the best of my knowledge which is why
the last strength came in the first
place what they the problem with them is
now they have to be one lip shits which
is they either have to clip the
gradients or regularize the gradients
that has their own set of problems and
and others observe more collapse in
there I'm sure if somebody takes my own
I don't know there must exist a data set
for which it's very hard to you know
there are so many real problems with
Gans right now FID score is the fresher
Inception distance is the only one we
know how to look at images and it brings
them down to some common latent space
assuming an existing model which acts as
a transformer in some sense and then you
compare those scores and see how close
they are and which is what Monaco is
show you tomorrow but is that the only
metric we don't really know how to
evaluate satanic data against Real data
that's a very fundamental questions
again
[Applause]
yes or the reception it was a wonderful